we uh did a show in san luis obispo not
long ago and and uh of course you're
part of my show with the cauliflower ear
a bit and uh you know when i when i
brought up your name i said the pride of
san luis obispo chuck liddell and and
you got a lot you always get a lot of
love every every time i do a shower say
your name man it's always a huge cheer
yeah and then the second part of the bit
when you're bleeding and you like caught
the blood everybody's like dude how
sweet you try to catch your blood you
know yeah yeah you're like we got blood
yeah
it's getting it's getting that injury on
your ear without the blood right because
you have it's
it once it once it pops it doesn't
it doesn't stay there you need it to
blow up
my buddy was draining his kids here like
he's eight-year-olds training his car
fire fire i was getting the blood out
how does an eight-year-old get
cauliflower here it happens all the time
wrestling right
yeah wow i didn't know eight-year-olds
wrestled
when did you get pregnant was pretty
good when did you get cauliflower here
mine's mine slowly grew i never never
blew up like mine just slowly grew over
time i mean i got a little bit inside my
ear blown up and it was so small i never
did anything about it
and it was like in my junior year and in
high school and then
i just grew through college and then
then wrestling now junior i have to
fight fighting afterwards i was doing
jiu jitsu and stuff and
when you get it are you like [__] yeah
i i did not want to have it like like
some of my friends nothing like this not
really but yeah it's a bad honor for a
lot of guys for sure ah dude i was
i i'm still upset that i wasn't able to
get it
america
if you thought jackass forever was crazy
oh boy do i have a show for you it's a
multimedia comedy show called the bucket
list tour and the stuff i filmed for
this show is way too hot for jackass
like the general anesthesia bike ride
the vasectomy olympics and sky jacking
the footage is so intense we have full
grown men passing out at almost every
city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you